continuing
the chapter of
which is vigilance
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
authored
and the narration of Omar.
And honestly this narration even in
the explanations of
is usually one of the longest
explanations of all the narrations
because this narration is the essence of
all of the narrations of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. However, we due to
the format of our talks, we want to make
it a little bit more
summarized.
so we've just gone over it for a few
days, for another couple days inshallah
to finish it. The narration of Omar with
respect to
etc.
Of course, this narration is on the
authority of Omar
Omar who is the second Khalifa
and his
and his daughter's name is Hafs. All
right. And she was one of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's wives. not
only one of his wives but one of his
closest confidants
and so much so that she was the one
who held on to the Quran that was
written in the time of Abu Bakr. She was
the one commissioned to keep it safe all
the way until the days of
in which
then made from it the mah that went
out to the various various
corners of the Muslim empire and he
passed away how many years after the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
how many years after him
13 right so a good way to remember this
is that the
of our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam means successorship
his successorship the successorship of
prophethood here not meaning that
they're prophets meaning that The extent
that prophethood will rule the Muslim
was 30 years. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said that it would be 30 years
long. After that
after 30 years it would be a kingship
just any other kingdom. Now
two years and some months for Abu Bakr.
He passed away at 63. The prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was how old
when he passed away? 63. Abu Bakr 63.
Which means that he was a couple years
younger than the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam. Omar was the youngest. So he
was the youngest between those three.
He passed away at 63 as well.
10 years after Abu Bakr 10 years and
some time. So if we add his time with
Abu Bakr's time, we have roughly 13
years. This places us at 23 after Hijra
when Omar passes away
then goes on. He takes the mantle and he
is the successor for roughly 12 years
or so and his was the longest.
After this he passes away and he passed
away in the year 35 after hijah.
35 after hijah.
After this Ali was the Khalifa for four
four and a half years roughly that
places us where 39 and a half years
after hij
was the Khalifa for 6 months
and then he stepped down for Muawya and
that sealed the successorship
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
Right. And they were in that order
and
alass
is not considered in that caliber.
Obviously he was very young when the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
passed away though he is his grandson.
However,
because of the his his lineage and
because of the goodness of his time in
those six months, albeit very short, it
is considered to be the seal of those 30
years, which places us at exactly 40
after Hijra. And this is when
became the first king in Islam. The
first king in Islam.
So
Jirel,
of course, at this point, the
companions, they don't know that this is
Gabriel yet. They think this is a very
strange man, very odd person with very
jarring features, but they don't know
that it is Gi yet.
And what would draw more attention?
For him to come in with very black hair
and very white clothing and none of them
recognized him, but he's not looking
a traveler. Would that be draw
people's attention more or for him to
come in from the beginning and it be
known that he is Jirelam?
Which would draw people's attention
more?
If they knew he was Gi, right? Of
course, this is Gi. As soon as he walks
in, they're told this is Gi.
Why didn't that happen?
They might. No, they wouldn't flee.
Maybe the Jews would flee, right?
The reason
because that's too much attention. Now
they're not going to listen to what he's
saying. Now they're going to be
hyperfixated on his features. This is an
angel. This is Gibl.
I wonder, you know, is this his real
form? Is that how many questions would
come up that would derail from the
intent of the narration?
So it was a balance, a balance of
drawing attention but not too much
attention. And this is the skill
of teaching. What is the skill of
teaching? The art of reciting the Quran,
of giving,
of teaching the legislation of Allah.
There is a balance. What is the balance?
that people are listening to the
message. However, they're not fixated on
the messenger
because that in itself is problematic.
You notice the best reciters are the
ones that make you forget about the
recer.
The best of are the ones that you forget
are even there. They take you to a place
and they get out of the way of the
message. And this is how
did this. Now he asked the prophet Sam
tell me about the hour.
And the prophet's response.
The person being asked has no more
knowledge of it than the one who is
asking
meaning of when it will be exactly when
it will proceed when it will start.
But we have indicators.
He then said,
"So tell me about its conditions or its
not conditions, but tell me about its
signs or its indicators that it is
drawing near." And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam gave us two no
more. Even though if we were to gather
all the narrations,
all of them that are authentic
acceptable, weak,
we would have a huge number of
narrations,
pushing towards
five, six or even 700 narrations, even
more. Some scholars place it at
over a thousand narrations regarding
the signs of the day of judgment. So why
then only two?
These two are types of things that will
happen. All other signs of the hour are
going to generally follow these two and
expound upon them. But more importantly,
these two are important because every
single
time and place
or these signs are ambiguous enough
that they can be applied to many times
throughout the history of this until
the day of judgment. This has been
around for a long time, 1,500 years,
1,500
years. This empire of faith is still
going very very strong. However, these
two nar these two signs of the day of
judgment, they are applicable to more
than a few of the junctions that this
has found itself upon. And we will
explain what that means in a moment
inshallah. He says the first sign
foreign.
[Silence]
And so he said the first is that a woman
will give birth to a woman here is not
just one woman or what is meant is a
phenomenon. This will occur. It will be
a commonplace occurrence that a woman
would give birth to her master
or give birth to her
female master.
Now what does that mean?
And what's interesting about this exact
words is that you look into the words of
the scholars
when they explain this narration,
you find something really really
interesting
that is that some of them
explain this
to be something that is very good, a
phenomenon that will occur that will be
part of the ummah's
greatness and then other explanations
point to this being something that is
very bad that will occur in the future.
One explanation
[Silence]
Best
tone.
in
the days of
slavery
was very different and that is that
had many many many ways that a person
could become a slave. many ways ranging
from being a prisoner of war to being
kidnapped from your own bed to being
lost in the desert and being found by a
caravan that takes you for takes
advantage of your situation and your
plight what happened with Ysefam
to even parents giving their children
into slavery to relieve themselves of
debts, right? All of these were ways
that a person could become a slave.
However, to be freed, there was only one
way to be freed,
and that was your master had to free
you. There was no other way. There was
no other way. If the master decided not
to free this slave, there was no way for
this slave to become free.
Now Islam came and it turned that
exactly 180. So it became that there is
only one way
to legally become a slave for a person
to legally in Islamic law find himself a
slave
to to wake up a slave.
And that is that a person is taken as a
prisoner of war. That is the only way.
No other way. There is no other way for
a free man to become a slave or a free
woman to become a slave other than in
war as prisoners of war.
However, the ways to be freed and
emancipated became extremely numerous.
Right? A person gets per person kills
a Muslim by accident. They free a slave.
A person breaks an oath, right? They
free a slave. A person has
intercourse with his wife in in the in
the day time of Ramadan when it's
obligatory upon them to fast, they free
a slave, right? things ranging from
personal
acts of worship between a servant and
Allah all the way to social levels where
for instance someone could purchase them
and free them or the person the slave
comes to the master and says I want to
be freed please I want my mukba and his
mukba is that he allows the master has
to allow the slave to purchase himself
from his master and as zaka and the
Muslimian are all obligated to help the
slave purchase his own emancipation.
Incredible.
And so when Islam came
and when the Muslim Empire expanded,
many people were brought into Islam into
the empire of Islam by way of being
prisoners of war. They were brought into
slavery. But what is amazing is that
slavery
is a thing that is set by one
generation.
It does not continue past the past one
generation in Islam.
That is that a slave woman her children
are free. A slave man his children are
free. They are no longer slaves. It is
only that one person
by default. And so if a woman has
a a woman who is a slave has a a child
from her master, that child is
automatically what? Born emancipated,
born free. The beauty of Islam and the
balance of Islam.
And so
this here where the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says that one of the signs of
the day of judgment is that a slave
woman would give birth to her own master
or her own female master. meaning that
she would have children into Islam, born
into Islam for her master and those
children would be would be emancipated
by default. They would be born into
emancipation
hence placing them in a position similar
to their parent who is the slave owner.
And so that is what that is a good
thing. Correct? This means that the
Muslim Empire will become so powerful
and its fruits will be bared so
numerously that a commonplace occurrence
is that droves of children and entire
generations would be born emancipated.
This is one explanation.
Another explanation is a very bad
explanation
and that is that
a woman
would give birth to a child
who as time continues and due to the
breakdown of society and the breakdown
of family and the breakdown of
lineage.
Later on, 20, 30 years down the line,
that daughter unknowingly
may purchase her own mother or may
purchase his own mother and become the
master of his own mother, not knowing
that this is actually his mother, not
knowing that her master is actually her,
her son. And this would only come as a
result of what?
Extreme ignorance.
Meaning that did you guys understand
that that one? Meaning that a woman
would give birth to a child. They would
then be separated
and each would continue their life
separate. And then 20 years later,
this child would be a grown man or a
grown woman at this point and purchase
this slave woman, not knowing that this
is actually her mother or not knowing
that this is actually his mother and
become the master of his own mother,
unknown, unbeknownst to him or her. And
and this would only happen in the case
of extreme
breakdown of the family unit, extreme
breakdown of lineage and in zena and
that adultery becomes very common place
and widespread. That is another
explanation. A third explanation
is that
what is meant here is not real slavery
as defined in the Quran and Sunnah.
What's meant here is the behavior of a
slave and master.
A figurative slave and master. That a
figurative slave woman would give birth
to her figurative master.
And this means that children will become
masters over their own parents.
And when will this happen? When
governments become so bloated and
tyrannical that they take away the given
right of Allah to the human being to
raise his own children. And so a child
is now estranged from his parent. And
now a child
is able to call the shots in his
relationship with his own parent as if
the child is the slave master and the
parent is the slave. The parent is
unable to discipline the child. The
parent is unable to get the child to be
obedient. And quite the opposite, the
parent will be obliged to the obedience
of his or her own child. And this will
only happen when the structure of the
family breaks down. People lose their
hold to Islam and the worship of Allah.
And when governments become so bloated
that they take away the rights of the
people to raise their own children, to
discipline their own children, to defend
themselves, to defend their blood, to
defend their property, when the
governments become so bloated and so
tyrannical and so intrusive that they
start to that they start to micromanage
every citizen household.
internally, not externally.
All of these, which one is the correct
opinion? Now, here's the part that is
really interesting, and we've gone a
little bit over our time. What's really
interesting about this?
If the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
wanted us to only understand one of
these meanings,
he would have said it in a way that only
one meaning could be understood.
Correct?
If he wanted to make it absolutely
crystal clear
that this one meaning here of these
three that I've just mentioned is the
intended meaning. He would have said it
in a way that that meaning would be the
only acceptable understanding in the way
that it's worded. So the question is why
is it left ambiguous?
lots of things with regards to science,
discoveries, the nature of the heavens
and the earth and the oceans and so
forth. And
prophecies of the future are ambiguous.
Some of them are super specific. Even
down to the names of certain people that
will be killed by other certain people.
This is how
this is how specific some narrations
are. Whilst others
say even the majority are very
ambiguous. Why? So that they can apply
to as many times and places as possible.
Which one of these is intended? All of
them. Some of those meanings are good.
Some of those meanings are bad. In this
one narration, in this one sentence,
he simultaneously prophesized
the greatness and rise of Islam to power
and simultaneously
prophesized that that power will later
fall. Just everything else human
beings do, your breath, it rises
and falls. And this is no different
except for this will never fall
entirely.
And so
a thousand years ago, the first
meaning was most appropriate for this
narration.
500 years ago, the second meaning was
most appropriate for this narration. And
now 1,500 years after these words left
our prophet's lips saiam
unfortunately the third meaning becomes
most appropriate.